[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première semaine du coworking à
paris saclay donc c'est une initiative
qui est née d'un groupe de travail 5le
d'innovation de paris saclay cinq
structures se sont réunis dans le cadre
en fait d'une communauté plus large qui
est là comité des lieux d'innovation que
le pea paris saclay à nîmes avec le
concours des trois plus grandes
agglomérations et des deux pôles
académique donc de de ce cluster de
paris saclay et l'idée justement c'était
de mettre en avant ces lieux de les
ouvrir au public et à différents types
de publics de population que ce soit le
grand public des entrepreneurs des
indépendants des salariés puisque
aujourd'hui on voit les modes de travail
qui sont en train d'évoluer et on a de
plus en plus besoin de ce type de lieux
qui sont hybrides entre le travail chez
soi et le travail au bureau ou en
entreprise et ça permet donc de créer
vraiment d ambiance assez sympathique et
plus créative pour l'ensemble de ces
populations
les cinq lieux qui ont composé le jeu
manceau groupe de travail des lieux de
coworking de paris saclay sont le 21 qui
est un tout nouveau pour le coup espace
de coworking à orsay sur le plateau de
saclay la terrasse discovery donc à
saint-aubin qui est opéré par la banque
populaire val de france le l'oma qui est
un espace plutôt dédié à tous qui est
environnement audiovisuel quitte à massy
la chambre de commerce de versailles et
enfin sur guyancourt generis accueillera
la dernière étape de cette semaine you
were kings et c'est un lieu plutôt
orienté prototypage
sur tout ce qui est électronique
mécanique
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la terrasse
discovery la deuxième étape de cette
semaine du coworking donc évidemment il
propose différents types d' espaces
c'est aussi un espace qui va accueillir
des formations puisqu'on ya un nombre de
salles de réunion assez importante et on
a également des grands espaces
événementiels pour accueillir voilà des
séminaires ou des réunions beaucoup plus
conséquente et devrait aussi prise prise
de conscience est de mise en action des
régions pour créer ce type de tir yeux
qui va permettre un petit peu de
réconcilier le travail foule bureau et
de travail complètement à la maison et
qui sont donc des lieux intermédiaires
mais également donc de partage on va
pouvoir retrouver un petit peu une
hybridation de ce qu'on retrouve au
bureau et dans ceux qu'on peut retrouver
à la maison en termes de confort de
travail
[Musique]